ich glaube zunächst mal ist klar das ist
einheitliche regeln gibt die jeder
versteht und die müssen auch so
kommuniziert werden
ich denke wir haben das jetzt in
deutschland endlich erreicht in den
letzten wochen
das war nicht immer so wir hatten ja
lange zeit ihnen endlose debatten auch
untereinander auch der minister war sie
denn mit dem kunterbunten mit uns was
ist jetzt der richtige weg wie viel
welche dosierung muss man es hat sich
gezeigt dass zögern am ende nicht
belohnt wird im gegenteil es braucht
klare regeln es braucht vernünftige die
jeder wahrnehmen kann wenn man schon
quasi ein juristisches staatsexamen
braucht und wir regeln zu verstehen dann
wird es sicherlich schwieriger insofern
glaube ich so wie vor sehr stark und
erklingen weil ich sagen haben wir jetzt
eigentlich eine gute basis die sollten
jetzt auch nicht vorzeitig aufgeben
wir haben keine verlässliche
einschätzung darüber wie sich
weihnachten und silvester
infektionsgeschehen ausgewirkt hat wir
können nicht sagen was mit dem urlaub
zurückkehren
den familien heimkehren ist und deswegen
wäre das aus meiner sicht nicht richtig
jetzt vorzeitig zu lockern sondern einen
klaren satz zu sagen wer heißt wir
müssen den lockdown leider ich sage das
ausdrücklich dazu leider weil es eine
einschränkung ist bei der bis ende
januar verlängert